et on continue à parler de ce sommet
très important qui va se tenir
aujourd'hui et demain à Bruxelles avec
vous Sandrine Gomez bonjour Sandrine
bonjour Pauline un sommet on l'a dit
avec Christophe à l'instant qu'il sommet
des divisions et des tensions dans le
couple franco-allemand oui entre les
deux pays c'est même le coup de froid
regardez cette une ce matin de du
quotidien Les Échos preuve que rien ne
va plus entre les deux capitales et bien
l'annulation de ce dîner de cette de ce
rendez-vous annuel du Conseil des
ministres franco-allemand c'est une
institution importante qui date depuis
de 2003 du temps de Jacques Chirac on
évoque ici et bien le long catalogue des
désaccords mutuels il y a notamment bien
sûr la gestion de la crise énergétique
la vision allemande est plus libérale
pas question ici de plafonner les prix
d'énergie les prix du gaz et là où ça
tangue sérieusement nous dit l'opinion
c'est sur le dossier de la défense
depuis l'annonce d'un projet allemand de
bouclier en antimissiles tourner vers
l'est le Royaume-Uni est associé mais
Pauline pas la France
qu'est-ce qu'on en dit dans la presse
allemande et bien le Der Spiegel j'ai
regardé dans son édito est assez
critique la France et l'Allemagne c'est
l'alliance des regards
je pense que je le dis mal c'est les
nombrilistes des pays qui ne pensent
qu'à leur propre intérêts merci merci
Christophe je n'ai pas fait d'allemand à
l'école donc des nombrilistes des pays
qui ne pensent qu'à leur propre intérêts
à leurs égoïsmes qui qui fragilisent
l'Europe dans leur lutte face à Vladimir
Poutine on pointe ici du doigt le
cavalier seul de l'Allemagne qui ont son
souviens à injecter un plan de 200
milliards d'euros au seul profit de ses
propres concitoyens au risque nous
dit-on ici de déstabiliser le marché
communautaire la France elle elle est
loin de donner l'exemple on rappelle que
malgré les engagements de baisse de la
consommation de gaz et bien on est
presque au même niveau en France d'avant
guerre en Ukraine
il y a pourtant lors d'une réunion du
Conseil de sécurité
la Russie Sandrine et l'Iran ont démenti
toute fourniture par terre de drones
armées à Moscou oui cette question des
sanctions elle va aussi être abordé lors
de ce Conseil européen c'est à la Une du
journal saoudien Arab news pour qui est
bien l'affaire est déjà pliée l'UE
impose regarder des sanctions contre les
drones
en Iran les drones iraniens la légende
de cette photo indique par ailleurs que
l'armée ukrainienne a battu au cours du
dernier mois plus de 220 drones
136 fourni par Téhéran on nous explique
ici que les 27 ont convenu ce mercredi
de mettre sur liste noire le fabricant
iranien de ces drones mais aussi deux
responsables des Gardiens de la
révolution des personnalités qui
supervisent notamment ce programme de
drone je suis allée plus vite que la
musique Sandrine donc il s'agissait de
cette réunion à
Bruxelles où il va être question de ces
drones dont on a parlé aussi à l'ONU et
donc des informations qui ont été
démenties effectivement la Russie et
l'Iran qui continue toujours de démentir
avec fermeté qu'il n'y a pas que l'Iran
ne vend pas de drones à la Russie
impliquée dans cette guerre en Ukraine
mais le problème c'est que l'épreuve est
bien elle s'accumule sur le terrain
regardez cette enquête du New York Times
des drones iraniens arrivent dans un
ciel déjà bondé d'Ukraine un ciel déjà
bondé pourquoi parce qu'il y a déjà de
nombreux drones qui sont utilisés de
part et d'autre des drones Turcs des
drones aussi américains le journaliste
détaille ici les deux types de drones
iraniens déployés dans cette guerre en
Ukraine il y a je l'ai dit les drones
kamikazes les chats de 36 conçus pour
exploser à l'impact et qui ont déjà été
utilisés par les outils dans la guerre
au Yémen et puis il y a d'autres drones
les mots à jr6 qui larguent eux deux
petites munitions alors cette
implication de l'Iran sur plusieurs
théâtres extérieurs suggèrent cette
analyse qui est à lire ce matin dans le
Jérusalem post que faut-il penser de la
présence des Gardiens de la révolution
en Crimée l'alliance Russo iranienne en
Syrie c'était le déplacée vers l'Ukraine
cette présence en Crimée des Gardiens de
la Révolution elle a été attestée par
plusieurs médias ces dernières semaines
ils viennent ici aider peut-on lire les
Russes dans le maniement des drones
iraniens une relation
héritée du conflit syrien puisque on
s'en souvient l'Iran tout comme la
Russie sont intervenus donc en Syrie en
soutien du président machin Alassane
et on finit sans transition aucune avec
un au revoir un homme de télévision et
de lettres j'en te l'ai oui un ce
romancier à succès nous a quitté trop
tôt à seulement 69 ans terrassé par une
crise cardiaque après une anthoxication
alimentaire Jean te les c'était toute
une histoire notre titre ce matin
libération lui qui fut tour à tour on le
rappelle dessinateur de BD chroniqueurs
télé à l'époque de nulle part ailleurs
sur Canal+ puis romancier poetico
historique il s'initie une vingtaine de
livres il nous laisse entre autres et
bien marquer de Montespan Charles neuf
crémant Baudelaire et puis son dernier
son dernier livre azaincourt par temps
de pluie il dira que c'est son
professeur de dessin à qui qui l'a sauvé
en lui donnant des cours d'histoire
libération donc je cite ici rend hommage
à un grand bosseur et un amuseur joyeux
un grand homme dans tous les